53 élus présents seulement au lieu de
100 habituellement les nouvelles règles
de distanciation physiques sont
respectées celle des passes d'armes
politique aussi et là rien de nouveau
les annoncer urbi et orbi quel sens
niveau pour la relance dont les contours
ne seront détaillées que le important et
qui seront votés sur l'aspect financier
indécent et kim seront dépensés en 2021
c'est partant du jour s'appelait encore
pour françois sauvadet ces mesures d'
aide aussi importante soit elle sont
beaucoup trop tardif pour lui c'est
maintenant que l'économie doit être
accompagné réponse de marie-guite dufay
un plan de relance doit se construire
ces 400 millions
il faut que nous les travaillons avec
tous les acteurs avec les entreprises
avec toutes nos grandes filières avec
les partenaires sociaux et avec l'état
et l'europe
donc tout cela c'est une grosse
mécanique qui va se mettre en oeuvre la
à partir de demain
loin de la polémique les premiers
concernés les chefs d'entreprise
applaudissent à ces nouvelles aides
annoncées
le medef se dit prêt à travailler avec
la région pour la mise en oeuvre du plan
de relance tout ne sera pas mis en place
il n'empêche qu'il faut pouvoir le
proposer faut pouvoir le soumettre et la
région fait son job en tant que
responsable de l'activité économique
aussi de l'accompagnement du
développement économique et nous
organisations patronales
on va être là pour soutenir pour
orienter pour peut-être réorienter de
temps en temps pour aller sur l'économie
réelle est là où il ya le plus de
potentiel de relance de l'économie
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
les aides d'urgence apportée par la
région pour amortir le choc économique
atteignent déjà les 100 millions d'euros